alors j'aime les rings tous ceux qui
vous aiment ont la chance de pouvoir
vous voir tous les soirs au théâtre des
champs elysées dans la pièce de
jean-claude carrière
l'aide mémoire et vous jane vous avez la
chance d'être tous les soirs dans les
bras de pierre arditi
c'est quand même une attraction
masculine ambulante qui est rare dit je
trouve et on paie qui a pété pardon vous
avez une alim
alors vous avez un sens du chien quand
même je suis havrais s'est excusé moi
bonnes choses contre le il était un bon
à savoir vous êtes sérieux mais bien sûr
je laisse ma vie j'ai jamais été aussi
serrée berry et riz en revenant sur abc
n'a rien à voir lui c'est bien beau mais
aussi dans ma loge
non non non non non je veux juste qu'on
passait ce que betty est une chienne
oui et que l'un d'entre nous s'appelle
bêtise sans nom et si on s'était étonné
c'est un bonheur bien sûr pas seulement
sa vilaine gentillesse ils ne me l'ont
dit parce qu'il ya des mecs mots qui
sont beaux et puis lui il m'a dit si tu
traînes bûche t'attrape 6 6 3 oui si tu
trébuche t'attrape situe un trou dans le
texte le remplir que demande le peuple
je sais moi c'était l'amour alors moi
j'ai les deux heures bon c'est bien
non non c'est déjà ça si vous avez ça
fait beaucoup rêver